Creo que este es el futuro de los medios.
Hasta hoy, las estrategias mediáticas y de cambio social
han intentado atraer a las masas,
pero el futuro es contenido personalizado para cada individuo.
A medida que la medición de consumo en tiempo real
y la producción automatizada de contenidos parece ser la norma,
pronto nos encontraremos consumiendo contenidos hechos a medida,
usando una mezcla de psicografía, biométricas e IA.
Es como medicina personalizada basada en nuestro ADN.
Yo los llamo "biocontenidos".
Actualmente estoy probando el Limbic Lab en un estudio piloto
con el Norman Lear Center,
que tiene acceso a las 50 mejores series de televisión.
Pero me veo en un dilema ético.
Si diseño una herramienta que se puede convertir en un arma,
¿debería construirla?
Al hacerlo en código abierto para fomentar el acceso y la inclusión
también corro el riesgo de permitir a poderosos gobiernos
y grandes compañías apropiarse de la plataforma
para crear noticias falsas, marketing u otras formas de persuasión masiva.
Para mí, por lo tanto, es crítico que mi investigación
sea lo más transparente posible para la audiencia laica.
Sin embargo, esto no es suficiente.
Como creadores tecnológicos
tenemos la responsabilidad
no solo de reflexionar cómo la tecnología actual
moldea nuestros valores y comportamiento,
sino también cómo desafiar activamente la trayectoria de la tecnología futura.
Espero que lleguemos a un compromiso ético
para aprovechar la inteligencia del cuerpo
para crear historias auténticas y justas
que transformen los medios y la tecnología
de armas peligrosas a medicina narrativa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y ovaciones)